Let's start with the
attack on Pelosi's husband, Paul Pelosi.
What is your reaction
It's disgusting.
This this this violence is horrible.
You know, that's happened.
We had a door knocker in Florida
that was attacked.
I mean, this stuff is has to stop.
One thing I did when I took over the NRC
a year
and a half ago is
I went to the Federal Election
Commission, said
could our candidates and our senators
use their campaign dollars
to pay for security?
Because as you know,
how sensitive members
don't have security,
most of them outside of D.C.
So but a lot of it is we got to
we've got to say, let's let's have a
we can have a heated conversation
about the issues,
but this violence has got to stop.
This is this is horrible.
And my heart goes out to Paul Pelosi.
And I hope he has a full recovery.
We've learned that the suspect's
social media
shows that he embraced
conspiracy theories
about the 2020 election.
And January six,
I want you to listen to what
President Biden said yesterday.
It's one thing to condemn the violence,
but you can't condemn the violence
unless you condemn those people
continue to argue
the election was not real
that is being stolen
that all the all the Milwaukee
that's been put out there
to undermine democracy.
Is he right?
Should Republicans
do more to reject
conspiracy theories
and dangerous rhetoric
I think what we have to do is, one,
we have to condemn the violence
and that we have to do everything
we can
to get people to make sure
people feel comfortable
about these elections.
You know, we've got to
we've got to do everything
we can to get
people comfortable
that this election in nine days
is going to be free and fair,
that people's votes are
all going to be counted fairly.
They're not going to be diluted.
And so that's one thing
I've tried to do at
the NRC is get people to make sure
we're ready.
I tell people,
go to the
go to the polls, vote,
go to the polls, and be poll watchers.
So you can see that these elections
are going to be free and fair.
And we've got to work on it
every every cycle,
get it better every every, every cycle.
To be fair, Senator,
most of your Republican colleagues,
even those in the Trump White House,
said that the 20, 20 election
was free and fair.
And that has not stopped
the conspiracies from flying.
So is it important for people
from the top of your party,
the former president, on down
to tone down
the rhetoric
about the conspiracies
that might instigate it,
somebody who is unhinged, like
the man who went into the Pelosi home
Then I think what's
important is everybody
do everything we can
to make these elections fair.
We've got Hillary Clinton
saying the 24 elections could be stolen.
We've got Stacey Abrams saying she didn't
she didn't lose.
Know.
So my job is
do everything I can to get people
to feel comfortable.
These elections are fair.
And I'm telling people get out to vote.
Colby, a poll watcher.
And when we have the opportunity,
let's make our election laws safer.
Let's make sure that you have voter I.D.,
you don't have ballot harvesting
you have monitor ballot box
that makes people feel more comfortable
that the elections are going to be fair.
And just to be clear,
I want to move on,
but there is no evidence
that they weren't fair in 2020.
I do want to move on to something
that's happening
happened in your home
state of Florida
which is
reporting that there were
anti-Semitic displays around
yesterday's Florida Georgia
football game in Jacksonville.
Their photos on social media
of people holding
anti-Semitic signs along the highway.
The message Kanye is right about
the Jews
was apparently projected
on the side of the stadium.
What's your reaction
machine mad?
You know I
became governor in January in 2011
and we were dealing with this
at one of our universities.
We've dealt with it.
I've had I've dealt with it as governor
and this anti-Semitism.
What I mean, it's it's disgusting.
It's wrong.
We have to push back against that.
And I mean, we've got to understand, we
we are blessed.
We live in a country
where we need to accept people.
We need to do
we can cherish our differences.
But let's let's accept people
and let's all live in a country
that we gets
we've got the best opportunity
in the world.
So let's quit dividing ourselves
and quit attacking other people.
And just talk about
how we make this a better place.
So this stuff is disgusting to me.
I've never understood
it, and it's disgusting to me.
Well, let's talk about your midterms.
Agenda.
Democrats say that
one of your proposals
that which would sunset
all federal legislation
after five years jeopardizes
Medicare and Social Security.
You've previously said that
those programs
need to be preserved,
reformed and protected.
So just a simple yes or no.
Do Republicans
want to cut Medicare
and or Social Security
Absolutely not.
And, you know, the Democrats
just cut $280 billion.
All Democrats in the Senate and House
voted to cut $280 billion
out of Medicare just to two months ago.
And then they want to say
Republicans want to cut something.
Democrats have done this.
So when he was sent
or said he wanted to cut Medicare
and Social Security,
I believe we got to preserve them
and make sure we we we keep them.
What I want to do
is make sure we live within our means
and make sure we preserve those programs.
People paid into them.
They believe in them.
I believe them.
I'm going to fight like hell
to make sure we preserve
Medicare and Social Security.
Just want to correct the record.
The Democrats plan, which is now law,
it didn't
cut social
excuse me,
it didn't cut Medicare benefits.
It allowed for negotiation
for prescription drug prices,
which would
ultimately bring down the price
and the cost for Medicare consumers.
But I want to ask the next question,
which is about raising.
Could we just finish that, though?
Is it cut to
and then it cut to an $80 billion
out of Medicare?
That means we're going to have fewer
life saving drugs.
It cut $280 billion in Medicare.
They can say they would
cut $80 billion
had benefits or reduce life saving drugs.
It didn't.
You can do that,
but you don't have
to make sure something's going to happen.
All right.
Come on.
I mean, I want to we can debate that
for a long time,
but I want to focus on
you and the Republicans
and what you want to do right now.
Do you support raising
the eligibility age for Medicare?
And Social Security?
No.
Okay.
Do you support
cutting back on Medicare benefits
or reducing Social Security payments
in order to keep the program solvent?
No, I don't.
No one Republican that does
and I know Joe Biden proposed
you know, he believed in these things.
He said it publicly when he was a U.S.
senator.
Let's talk about
another part of your plan
which calls for permanently
extending the 2017 Trump tax cuts.
Many economists say
that could make inflation worse.
The nonpartisan
Congressional Budget Office
says it would add
almost $3 trillion to the deficit.
So how is that fiscally responsible
Well, here's my experience.
I cut taxes and fees
100 times as governor of Florida,
and my revenues grew.
Revenues grew with the Trump tax cuts.
They didn't go down.
They grew with the Trump tax cuts.
Inflation is caused
by not living within our means,
by having a government
that spends more than
it takes in buy,
because in a regulatory environment
that makes it difficult
for people to produce foods.
Having a regulatory environment
that causes gas prices to go
up, have diesel prices
to go up, and natural gas prices go up.
That's what causes inflation.
Inflation is not caused
because you cut taxes. Government is not.
Government does not create the economy.
Individuals create the economy.
Businesses create the
economy, not government.
Well.
Okay. Well,
on the question of inflation,
the Congressional Budget Office
is the one that said that
reviving the Trump
tax cuts, extending them permanently.
I should say
would add
almost $3 trillion to the deficit.
You think they're wrong?
That's.
That's assuming
you don't grow the economy.
I mean,
I cut taxes
100 times and fees at times as government
revenues grew
because you start building
the private sector.
We got to make government smaller,
the private sector bigger.
That's what we have to do.
This idea that government can build
an economy is just a complete fallacy.
And it's never worked anywhere.
It does it.
It's not worked.
As we get bigger and bigger government,
we get more and more inflation.
I mean, it's very consistent.
The election is just nine days away.
You have been crisscrossing the country.
Senator Chuck Schumer
was caught on a hot mic.
I know you probably saw this.
He gave his midterm assessment.
He's optimistic
about Pennsylvania and Nevada not.
But he said he's going
the Democrats are going
downhill, rather, in Georgia.
So which battleground states
do you think Republicans
will win on Election Day?
How many Senate seats will
the GOP control next year?
Where to get 52 plus.
Herschel Walker a win in Georgia.
We're going to keep all 21 of ours
as is going to win
against Fetterman in Pennsylvania.
I Adam Laxalt win in Nevada
but I think we have
every reason
believe we can pick up with Blake master
in Arizona with Don Baldwin.
I'll be going to
North Carolina New Hampshire today
I think Don Bolduc has every reason
to believe he's going to win.
But we've got shots in with 50 smiling
Washington Joe Day in Colorado.
They are leaving Connecticut.
We this is this is our year.
The Democrats can't run on anything
they've done.
People don't like what they've done.
They don't like high inflation.
They don't like gas prices.
Food prices up. They don't like it.
The public doesn't like an open border.
They don't like
they don't like high crime.
And that's what
the Democrats are known for.
I mean, they've done all these things.
Democrats did it.
So they did it.
They want to run away from it.
We're almost out of time before we go.
President Trump is going to campaign
with your Florida colleague,
Senator Marco Rubio, in Miami
ahead of Election Day.
The rally notably will not feature
your successor as Governor Ron DeSantis,
who is also on the ballot this year.
Should Governor
DeSantis be at that rally with
Donald Trump and Marco Rubio?
My attitude to everybody,
everybody makes
I mean, I know
President Trump is trying to make sure
we get a majority back in the Senate.
He's he spent,
I think, $20 million in ads.
He's doing rallies.
He's helped us raise money.
He's doing voter contact.
So I know he wants to help us win.
I'm doing everything I can to help
Republicans win all across the country.
We've we've canvas
we've gone all over the country.
I was with Ronna McDaniel,
the chair of the RNC.
So you're okay with John McCain?
He's doing the same thing.
You're okay with Governor
DeSantis not being.
Oh, yeah.
Is a choice he makes. Yeah, absolutely.
Okay.
Senator Rick Scott of Florida,
thank you so much for joining me.